i
[Music]
good
well first of all thank you very much
to google for giving us the opportunity
to tell about our experience with
bridge query we have actually been
using mi fue y
for three years and it has been quite
complicated trying to summarize all the
material  that I am going to give here today
because the truth is that since we have been
using vico 'little we have obtained the
number of those products and tools with
business applicability that I
would like to tell you about but that we have had
to summarize because it is impossible
in this short period of time
to contextualize  what we do from
bbb research we have entitled in the
presentation between large brokers in the
first place we give a brief
introduction to what is level and as a
school and has helped us to its
exploitation level in the main
external database on the scale of big
data that we use  To enrich
our
analysis below, after this brief
introduction, we will show all the
products that we have developed from
bv research that can basically be
grouped into two large blocks:
geopolitical and social
analysis and digital economic analysis
and it is an open source database
that collects information from the press,
radio, television and online news on
an international national scale.  regional and
local information in more than 65 languages, obtaining
a large amount of
georeferenced information from 1979 to today in
almost real time, it collects information and is
updated every 15 minutes, it
collects events that
were initially oriented to
geopolitical and social winds but that
Later, new terms have been introduced. It
includes a lot of information of an
economic, financial and digital nature. All
articles are translated in real time into
English and are processed by a wide
range of algorithms that allow us to
identify hundreds of categories of
events, from protests to peace appeals.
allows us to identify thousands of
emo  tions from anxiety to
happiness millions of topics from
commerce to cyberattack as well as
places, organizations and people in
this way helps us understand and
monitor the world what happens in
real time
to manage all that amount of
information stored in the cloud
we use bitcoin that helps us
consult, export and
analyze all these amounts of information
and the inclusion of the level in beat cueli
has been a fundamental milestone in the
availability and use of lidl because it
has not allowed us to process a large amount
of information in almost no time  real in
a very fast simple way and in one
in a source with free access, in
addition to highlighting that the scalability
and flexibility that level gives us
makes it compatible with a dynamic scheme
that can combine the constant addition
of information to databases
as well as  an environment that combines both
real-time and
historical information
because how does all this fit into
our workflow once
this information has been brought from bv to research with
special care in the treatment,
cleaning and analysis of the data because
as Álvaro commented earlier,
the data itself is not going to tell us what we
want  Listening has to be the
analyst with his knowledge,
experience and strategic vision
who poses the right questions that he
wants to solve based on the data and that is
where we provide
added value where we structure all this
information and process all this
information to be able to answer new ones
questions and enrich our analysis. In
addition, it should be noted that here
the high volume of
information and data is very important, knowing how to
transmit this information in
a direct and simple way that is capable
of reaching the
entire public. For this, since we were 16,
we have used different tools that
They range from cardboard maps to network
analysis and network  s using
wifi hare
why it is important and how it has
contributed to improving the analysis
we carry out within bbva research the use
of itei live query has allowed us to
quantify trends for which until
now we only had
qualitative information and therefore answer
questions that until now  had no
answer, in addition, the emotional analysis
has not allowed us to investigate the study
and the knowledge about
the evolution of sentiment, in addition to
the geographical dimension, which
has allowed us to advance in everything
that is known as what it did in
intelligence  that is to say, based on the
relationships between the geospatial data,
knowing how to identify where an
event with a conflict takes place and how it can
spread geographically towards other
heists of geographies.
With all this we have created a battery
of products that, as I mentioned, is
difficult to synthesize here today, but  ranging
from real-time index creation
to the sec  uence of
social trends to the creation of
hybrid indices that use both real data
and data at the scale of
big data information to obtain
real-time monitoring of the evolution of
economic and social trends, we
also do sentiment
analysis, social network analysis and
then  I am going to tell a little more
detail about all this, some of our
example within the geopolitical sphere,
we monitor
conflicts around the world on a daily basis, on
these maps here, what you can see is
the dynamics of the conflict over
time until  May, both the
world-wide area and the Middle East area,
as you can see, quickly gives us
insights and allows us to identify where it
has its place
in the main hot
spots, points of conflict in the world, which, as
you can see, are located in the
East area  medium if we make a map
we can go more specifically to the specific point
where you are having the  place at
that time the conflict that as we see
were located mainly in the area of
iraq afghanistan yemen we al
o see something in the sunset icahn in the balka
s due to the passage of refugees also
his innovative database allow
us to obtain and perform the analy
is of  the historical perspective of all
these social trends in this case
we show the index of conflicts and
protests at the global level aggregated since
1979 and in color what you can see
is how this index of
protest evolves for each of the
countries throughout  of time allowing us to
quickly identify sources of tension
as well as possible contagion effects what
we can see one of the insights that
these graphs offer us is the
social awakening of the Arab spring
in 2011 as seen in the
protest graph in the graph of  conflict
you can also see how the trend
since the 90's has reversed and for
you we have an upward trend
which can  from being quite worrying
so in the color we can identify
perfectly and the West is
now in a fairly calm situation
after the year
80 communism as well as as we mentioned
before the emergence of the
Arab spring in the entire North African area
of this perfection  history we are going
to analyze burning issues in real time
these two graphs that I show you
here today are a good example of this in the
first map we can see
how the migratory flows that
emerged through the crisis in syria evolve
the advance of the Islamic state and  all the
instability of the region where the
red dots indicate the departure of
refugees and the orange dots
where we are going as we can see they come from the area
of the middle east and north africa passi
g through turkey that collects the largest numbe
of these refugees greece and its passa
e  through the Balkans until we reach
Central Europe,
another issue that worries us a lot
and is called very  close is the increase
in tensions in north korea in
this 30th here you can see its
evolution over time compared to the
evolution of the conflict worldwide
this indicator that we follow in
real time has allowed us to identify in
advance that they were  increasing
the intensity of protests and conflicts
in this area before the rapid increase
that we have seen in recent months due to all
the tests that it has carried out with its
nuclear program
in the same way with this dynamic
we can do a
geolocated monitoring at street level to
identify  where the
protest or conflict or event in
question takes place and thus obtain the maximum
potential of the data,
all this as I mentioned, we follow it in
real time in this case the examples
are for the case of cairo
the 2011 protest the case of turkey
in 2015  the case in junco in 2014
on this map from here passing us now to
the economic and digital sphere what we
can see is the perception  and
feeling towards Spain in
the press both internationally,
as I mentioned, and locally in the
different regions on a daily basis,
where we can clearly identify in
which areas there is a better perception
of Spain, in which there is a
more negative perception and  how this
perception has been changing
over time
another example that I would like to highlight is
the follow-up that the
perception
of China's economic slowdown has liked both the
geographical dimension and the relational dimension
to obtain with the network analysis
to obtain  the relations of the rest of the
countries with china in this case what we
can observe is that we have found
clusters that communities of countries
based on their relationship with china and how they
are geographically distributed here
in this case the main core the main crater
is formed by the usa  The United Kingdom,
India and Japan, which are the
main trading partners and
China's financial markets and they are the
main countries that, as you can see
in the heat map where it appears that
this issue
of China's economic slowdown is discussed the most, are
the ones that are most concerned about what is
happening in China
in the rest of the network, such as  you can
identify it more or less attends to its
relationship and geographical distribution
following the theme of china another
example that has allowed us and has
given us many insights when
combining real data raw
data with big data is this indicator
to monitor  in real time
of China's economic vulnerability,
this indicator, as you mentioned, mixes both
types of information and we can
disaggregate it into four components that
will tell us what is the main
source of vulnerability that is
occurring in China,
another very interesting topic that we
have  much impetus has been put into it and what is
quite curious is the subject of
narratives and how the perception
that one has depends on  Going from the language
of the article, an example that clarifies
very well what we want to show is the
case of Turkey where here what we
show is the evolution of the Turkish GDP
and we compare it with the evolution of the
perception that Turkey has in the
media  in the
english press and in the turkish press that we observe
that the english company, in addition to
correlating worse with the evolution of
gdp, as we can see, is much less moving
there is systematically more negative
than the turkish press, which, as we can see,
correlates much better with the
evolution of economic activity  in
this of burberry being we were
working hard to advance in this
analysis of sentiments and how in the
narrative it can change the perception
that is had until the song is determined
the theme
and finally I would also like to
comment on an indicator that we have taken
in high frequency to measure  the
evolution of digital sentiment in
all countries through this
indicator r  we collect a set of more than 60
variables that can be grouped into
fintech digital economy and regulation can
be disaggregated by country here those
shown by region to see how
all these issues evolve
over time and above all have that image
and that comparability of  where it was
better or worse commented
well basically this is all I
wanted to tell and here you can visit us
and find more analysis of the 3 that we have
done in this regard and without further ado give the
floor to my colleague Juan María great
[Applause]
[Music]